so there's a clip going viral of her
asking her where is the strangest place
her and John has gotten sex is not for
the internet yeah and well you know I
could imagine if some of the wives I
said previously were ass this they would
just say that's private it's between
husband and wife but Christy just goes
on tell everybody is this the best or
the worst what are you doing the best
okay the
best um probably the Obama thing
what
what's oh God God John what what what is
what is your wife talking about I don't
know we heard in there get back in what
happened we're not going to discuss that
we're not going to discuss it we're not
we're oh my God Secret Service come here
jump back in look at look at I don't
we're not talking about it that's the
truth that is an awesome answer